everyone its definition here with
another unboxing review at this time
I've got the Wonder Woman box so no
one's coming out it so first bit it's
the Wonder Woman box the pins falling
[Music]
paper so you know it's telling me
everything we also got some Wonder Woman
socks they can go out the window next
one's the Funko pop very rare Funko pop
I don't really collect them myself but
I'm sure you know a little kids love
that there's only little kids collect
them your girlfriend called some dust
collectors fine size heroes not the size
of a pint if that's what they call a
pint in America no wonder they're all
lightweight ha ha ha just a little
little joke about my American cousins
don't unsubscribe a few from America and
the final pop is a Wonder Woman 1 this
box we get two Funko pops in like I said
don't collect them up in that job again
and well you're really happy with that
one that's definitely one that's right
up my street when you collect these
things you haven't got much chance of
ever seeing a real woman so it could
have little plastic ones instead if you
want to check out my Wonder Woman review
or my comic reviews come look over here
come look over here i'm reviewing all
these comics on my website at definition
cora UK and we read through all the
Batman ones from start to finish at the
moment and sort of work another Justice
League new 52 ones so I'd appreciate it
if you check that out click subscribe or
I'll find it and I'll put a box in your
head like boxing anyway take care bye